guten Abend Herr Knaus guten Abend sie
sagen
in der Flüchtlingspolitik braucht es ein
komplettes Umdenken wie kann das
aussehen ja das Interessante ist ja dass
die Ampelkoalition Ende 221 einen
Koalitionsvertrag vorgelegt hat der
diesen kompletten Umbruch mit dem Titel
Paradigmenwechsel verspricht und der
auch sehr detailliert sagt was die Ziele
sind weniger irreguläre Migration im
Einklang mit der Menschenwürde und dem
Konventionen und
Menschenrechten und das durch
migrationsabkommen inklusive der
Möglichkeit in Drittstaaten
Asylverfahren durchzuführen so das steht
da jetzt im
ampelvertrag wenn das umgesetzt würde
bedeutet es tatsächlich einige
drastische Änderungen und die sind bis
jetzt nicht erfolgt die Zahl der
irregulär nach Europa kommenden Menschen
steigt
immer mehr nach Griechenland als mehr
als im letzten Jahr mehr nach Italien
als im letzten Jahr auch jetzt mehr nach
Spanien als im letzten Jahr und die die
Europa erreichen ein immer größerer
Anteil kommt nach
Deutschland also hier gilt es jetzt vor
dem Hintergrund dass ja auch noch die
Rekordzahl von ukrainischen Flüchtlingen
aufgenommen wurde eine historische Zahl
von Menschen
aufzunehmen und das verlangt nach
Maßnahmen die mehr sind als nur Rhetorik
mhm gehen wir mal drauf ein also
Asylverfahren in Deutschland das würde
im Prinzip bedeuten die Antragsteller
kommen in Deutschland an kommen da eine
Unterkunft und von da aus dann erstmal
in einen Drittstaat und da soll dann der
Antrag bearbeitet werden da gibt's ja
unglaublich viele offene Fragen oder
also wie würden die Menschen
untergebracht werden werden deutsche
Beamte vor Ort was würde dann überhaupt
passieren wenn der Antrag abgelehnt
ist nein ich glaube dass das auch zeigt
wie wie wenig intensiv und das erklärt
vielleicht die Schwierigkeiten der
letzten Tage und auch des heutigen Tages
die Schwierigkeiten noch innerhalb der
Parteien zu Vorschlägen zu kommen die
Parteien diskutieren intern sehr
intensiv in der SPD in der CDU unter den
Grünen der Vorschlag der eine Chance
hätte umgesetzt zu werden bezieht sich
nicht darauf Leute aus Deutschland in
einen sicheren Drittstaat zu bringen das
halte ich für nicht durchsetzbar nicht
umsetzbar sondern zu sagen ab einem
Stichtag wie bei der eu-türkeier
Erklärung
2016 oder wie in dem zwischen
Großbritannien und Ruanda vereinbarten
Memorandum ab einem Stichtag werden
diejenigen die dann über das Mittelmeer
über die egis aus Libyen Tunesien
Spanien oder der Türkei in die EU kommen
von dort in einen sicheren Drittstaat
gebracht damit die Verfahren dort
stattfinden mit dem ganz expliziten Ziel
dass dann sehr sehr schnell sich sehr
viel weniger Menschen wie das auch 2016
passiert ist in die Bote setzen also
Deutschland müsste hier einerseits mit
Griechenland gemeinsam und wer immer
sich anschließt ein Angebot an die
Türkei machen das Abkommen von 20116
wiederbeleben und andererseits mit
Italien und einer Gruppe von anderen
Staaten ein Abkommen machen mit einem
sicheren Drittstaat wie z.B Ruanda wo
seit 19 der UNHCR genau das schon macht
Leute hinbringt und dann dort die
Asylverfahren durchführt
also die Idee ist hier die irreguläre
Migration in die EU so zu reduzieren wie
das zum Teil bereits gemacht wurde oder
von verschiedenen Staaten in Europa auch
schon im Detail aus
ausgearbeitetm also sie sagen im Prinzip
soll es denn eine Stichtagsregelung
geben dass damit jeder weiß ab dem Tag X
wird das eben gehandhabt und sie haben
aber eben auch schon mal gesagt dass das
ja eigentlich alles schon mehr oder
weniger im Koalitionsvertrag drin steht
jetzt wird heute Abend darüber
gestritten ob das denn überhaupt gemacht
wird m müsste die Politik da nicht schon
viel viel weiter
sein es kommen halt zwei Dinge zusammen
wir haben eine hohe Zahl von
Asylsuchenden und wir haben eine
Rekordzahl von ukrainischen Flüchtlingen
die aufgenommen wurden und der Krieg ist
ja nicht vorbei also wenn man sieht die
Umfragen in den deutschen Kommunen äh es
ist ja interessant die Reaktionen darauf
es gab eine Umfrage vor wenigen Tagen
40% sagen sie sind eigentlich in einem
Notstand 60% sagen sie könnten noch
Leute aufnehmen und manche sagen ja das
ist ja gut da gibt's ja kein Problem
aber wir müssen natürlich wissen es
können ja noch hundertausende Ukrainer
kommen in diesem Winter im nächsten Jahr
der Krieg ist nicht vorbei und es werden
auch weiterhin Asylsuchende kommen also
es wäre
fahrlässig jetzt nicht zu versuchen äh
zwei Dinge zu machen mehr Solidarität in
Europa dass mehr Staaten auch
Bedingungen anbieten dass auch Ukrainer
etwa nach Frankreich gehen oder nach
Italien oder Spanien oder
Schweden Frankreich hat halb so viele
Ukrainerinnen aufgenommen wie
Baden-Württemberg und gleichzeitig die
Zahl der Asylanträge
zu reduzieren während sie derzeit
steigen und das ist tatsächlich im
Koalitionsvertrag explizit das Ziel da
steht zweimal im Kapitel zu Migration
wir die Regierung wollen irreguläre
Migration reduzieren damals gab es
190.000 Asylanträge in Deutschland in
diesem Jahr werden es vielleicht über
300 000 sein und meine Frage ist dann
und ich glaube die Frage stellen sich
viele in Deutschland ja haben das die
Koalitionäre die das verhandelt haben
ernst gemeint denn manche Dinge wie z.B
das Reduzieren von aussichtslosen
Asylanträgen aus sicheren
herkunftstaaten wie Georgien und Moldau
wo 9000 Asylanträge im letzten Jahr zu
25 mal irgendeiner Form von Schutz
geführt haben dass man darüber immer
noch diskutiert
das zeigt dass dieses Ziel irreguläre
Migration human und im Einklang mit den
Menschenrechten zu reduzieren bis jetzt
nicht das zentrale Ziel der Koalition
war und jetzt brennt es an allen Ecken
und Enden und wenn nichts passiert
werden im nächsten Jahr die Zahlen
weiter steigen gleichzeitig hat dann die
Koalition trotz einines guten
Koalitionsvertrags kein Konzept mit dem
sie in den europaparlamentswahlen oder
in den Landtagswahlen im nächsten Jahr
äh werben kann für etwas was am Ende
Kontrolle herstellt wie sie versprochen
hat mhm wir sprechen die ganze Zeit über
Ruanda über dieses Ruanda Modell
Großbritannien hat ja eine entsprechende
Vereinbarung mit Ruanda und der
Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte hat dann im Juni einen
britischen Flug einen Abschiebeflug
dahin gestoppt die Frage ist ist es denn
überhaupt sinnvoll über solche Maßnahmen
nachzudenken wenn von vorne rein klar
ist dass sie rechtlich wirklich
schwierig
sind ja also zunächst zu zu Rwanda der
UNHCR bringt seit 2019 Menschen nach
Ruanda und dort machen er die
Asylverfahren
äh das wurde vom UNHCR hohen ar das ist
die UN
flüchtlingsorganisation mehrfach gelobt
und Großbritannien hat ein Abkommen das
von einem englischen nicht vom
europäischen Gericht von einem
englischen Berufungsgericht im Sommer
mit dem Argument gestoppt wurde dass
Rwanda derzeit und das war eine sehr
kluge
Gerichtsentscheidung noch nicht
glaubwürdige Asylverfahren durchführen
kann weil die Idee ist Leute werden nach
einem Stichtag die vom Ärmelkanal also
von Frankreich aus über den Ärmel Kanal
nach Großbritannien kommen mit dem Boten
nach Randa gebracht und dort gibt es die
Asylverfahren und die bleiben dann wenn
sie anerkannt werden auch dort und das
englische Gericht hat gesagt wir glauben
nicht dass Rwanda derzeit faere
Asylverfahren treffen kann aber die
Antwort darauf und das ist mein
Vorschlag auch an die deutsche Politik
und an die europäische Politik an Länder
die das machen wollen ist dass der UNHCR
der das ja bereits macht und seit
Jahrzehnten gemacht hat für die die dor
hin gebracht werden
Entschuldigung Verzeigung für die die
dor hin gebracht werden auch die
Asylverfahren machen kann und dann wäre
diese Bedingung erfüllt okay ich schau
mal gerade in den Chat da gibt es
nämlich auch Fragen zum einen die FR
genau hier wird darüber diskutiert in
wieefern Deutschland denn mit der EU
zusammenarbeiten sollte also zum einen
gibt's sie Frage kann Deutschland das
Asylrecht nur mit Europa begrenzen oder
es gibt einen Kommentar da sagt
Sebastian Deutschland kann das Problem
auch ohne die EU lösen eine europäische
Einigung ist sowieso nicht in Sicht ein
Blick nach Dänemark hilft wie sehen Sie
das also wir haben ja seit Jahren jetzt
eine Diskussion über eine große
europäische asylrechtsreform
äh diese
asylrechtsreform jeder der sie sich
ansieht und ich habe mit vielen
Regierungen gesprochen
weiß die wird im Grunde sehr sehr wenig
ändern fast nichts ändern sie ist nicht
wirklich die dramatische Verschärfung
die manche Kritiker in ihr sehen vieles
was da beschlossen wird war auch bis
jetzt schon möglich aber sie wird auch
nicht irreguläre Migration reduzieren
das heißt diese große äh dieser große
Versuch über Gesetzesänderungen in
Europa ein besseres effizienteres
humaneres System zu finden ich halte ihn
für gescheitert das wird allerdings erst
im Laufe der nächsten Jahre klar werden
derzeit wollen alle einfach einen
Abschluss dieser Gespräche um irgendwie
sagen zu können es war nicht ganz
vergebens aber für das nächste Jahr wird
das in jedem Fall keinen Einfluss haben
äh in der Zwischenzeit verhandeln
europäische Staaten alle bilateral
Italien hat heute ein Memorandum mit
Albanien präsentiert griechenland hat im
letzten Jahr ein Memorandum mit
Bangladesch ausverhandelt Spanien redet
direkt mit Marokko und westafrikanischen
Staaten das ist legitim weil Staaten ja
auch verschiedene Interessen haben
solange es im Einklang mit den
Grundwerten der EU ist daher ist mein
Vorschlag natürlich kann man immer nur
europäische Lösungen äh finden weil man
ja die Transitstaaten also die
außengrenzstaaten der EU braucht Italien
um mit Afrika zu verhandeln um
Rückführungen zu machen Griechenland für
die Türkei also es es kann nie
Deutschland ganz alleine einen großen
Durchbruch erzielen aber Koalitionen von
Staaten die gemeinsame Interessen haben
und was mich auch wundert ist dass
darüber noch nicht ernsthaft gesprochen
wird nehmen wir z.B die Türkei
Griechenland hat vor vielen Wochen ja
schon Monaten der griechische
migrationsminister gesagt wir wollen ein
neues Angebot an die Türkei machen ich
weiß es gibt auch schon Gespräche aber
die wirkliche klare Diskussion wie 26
was ist man bereit und mit wem in der EU
ist man bereit was
anzubieten die sehe ich noch nicht um
einen Erfolg in den Verhandlungen mit
der Türkei zu erzielen also wenn
Präsident Erdogan in Wochen ja jetzt
bald nach Berlin kommt gibt es dann
schon ein
möglicherweise unterschriftsreich
unterschriftsreifes Memorandum das
attraktiv genug ist dass die Lehren
zieht aus dem was 20116 geklappt hat und
was nicht geklappt hat und dass dann in
der EGS einen Durchbruch verspricht der
schon ab dem Winter und im nächsten Jahr
mehr Kontrolle herstellt ich weiß noch
nichts von so einem Vorschlag die
Griechen wussten auch noch nichts als
ich vor kurzem mit dem griechischen
migrationsminister gesprochen habe also
die konkrete Arbeit an einem
historischen Abkommen mit einem sicheren
Drittstaat mit der Türkei mit einem
wichtigen Herkunftsland wie Irak
es wird mit vielen geredet
der
migrationsbeauftragte Joachim stamp ist
viel unterwegs bereitet vor ist
im Knüpfen von Beziehungen im Aufbau von
Vertrauen führt Gespräche aber die
letzte Entscheidung ist Chefsache und
das muss der Kanzler und das müssen die
parteichfs der Ampelkoalition
entscheiden was sind Sie bereit
anzubieten und da ist die Debatte noch
sehr Waage aber jetzt haben sich die
Bundesländer ja zumindest heute
Nachmittag darauf einigen können dass ä
das türkeiabkommen wiederbelebt werden
muss Frage warum muss es überhaupt
wiederbelebt werden warum hat's nicht
gehalten na ja das Abkommen war gedacht
es ist ja nur eine Presseerklärung es
hat ja vor allem einen politischen
Charakter aber es war die mächtigste und
wichtigste Presseerklärung der letzten
10 Jahre im Migrationsbereich es hat
dazu geführt dass für viele Jahre sehr
wenige Menschen kamen aber die Türkei
hat natürlich darauf gedränkt dass sie
auch etwas davon hat und nach vier
Jahren in denen die Türken bereit waren
die die in Griechenland ankommen
zurückzunehmen
hat die Türkei das ausgesetzt im März
2020 also seit März nimmt die Türkei
niemanden mehr zurück
es ist auch nicht mehr ganz klar was die
EU der Türkei verspricht die Zahl der
aus der Türkei aufgenommenen Syrer die
sollte ja kompensieren das sollte ja ein
humanitäres Aufnahmeprogramm beginnen
das hat auch noch nicht wirklich
begonnen die Visaliberalisierung das
große Versprechen für die türkischen
Bürger
steckt zum Großteil auch weil die Türkei
manche Bedingungen nicht erfüllt hat
aber darüber redet man auch kaum noch
also das das Grundproblem war
wie geht's jetzt weiter so dass die
Türken ein Interesse haben zu
kooperieren die Europäer und vor allem
die deutschen Österreicher und Griechen
die hauptzielländer von denen die über
die Türkei in die EU kommen haben eine
riesen interteresse zu kooperieren und
die Frage ist jetzt was bietet man an
und das wird dann schnell kompliziert
denn wenn man z.B über Visa redet
derzeit kommen viele Türken in die EU
stellen einen Asylantrag es ist
mittlerweile eine der Haupt herkunfts
eines der hauptherkunftsländer für
Asylanträge und
wenn man jetzt es leichter macht zu
reisen müsste man das auch kombinieren
natürlich mit der Zusage der Türkei ihre
eigenen abgelehnten
Bürger zurückzunehmen man müsste die
Menschenrechte in der Türkei müssten
sich verbessern man müsste fragen was
bietet man gleich an und was kommt
später wie viel Geld bietet man an
bietet man an Syrer aufzunehmen all
diese Fragen äh müssen eigentlich sind
politisch brisant müssen müssen
eigentlich jetzt im Detail diskutiert
werden um dann in naher Zukunft den
Türken wie im März 2016 ein Angebot
vorzulegen dass sie nicht ablehnen
wollen und das würde tatsächlich wieder
Kontrolle humane Kontrolle herstellen
und dazu muss man ja auch sagen dass das
Verhältnis zu Präsident Erdogan in
letzter Zeit dann auch nicht besser
geworden ist vielleicht noch mal eine
Frage zu den
migrationsabkommen zusammenfassend wäre
das denn dann die eine Lösung die die
Migrationsfrage in Deutschland
löst also wir wissen was nicht viel
nützen wird wir haben schon gesagt die
EU asylreform wird wenig nützen ich bin
überzeugt Binnengrenzkontrollen die
jetzt eingeführt werden werden die Zahl
der Asylanträge nicht wirklich
reduzieren das war weder in Österreich
noch in Frankreich noch sonst wo der
Fall äh ich bin skeptisch dass es
gelingen wird sehr viel mehr Leute
abzuschieben manche der Reformen der
letzten Tage die diskutiert und
beschlossen wurden sind sinnvoll aber
sie werden die die Zahlen nicht
dramatisch erhöhen das geht gar nicht
also ist die Grundfrage wie kann
Deutschland irreguläre Migration
reduzieren immer eine Frage wie schafft
man es dass weniger Menschen irregulär
in die EU kommen und das geht nur durch
Kooperation
migrationsabkommen ist schon fast ein
Klischee ja es gibt schlechte und gute
es gibt das mit Tunesien was nichts
bringt es gibt welche die sehr viel
gebracht haben und sehr schnell wirken
können der Kern besteht in den Details
aber grundsätzlich ist es nicht möglich
irreguläre Migration wenn man nicht auf
Gewalt und Bruch der Gesetze setzt und
Leute einfach zurückstößt mit Gewalt mit
Soldaten was illegal ist dann muss man
Leute zurückbringen entweder in ein
Transit oder in ein herkunftstaat nach
einem Verfahren oder in einen sicheren
Drittstaat und dazu braucht man
Einigungen und ohne die geht es nicht
das Entscheidende ist jetzt dass
Deutschland an den richtigen wichtigen
strategischen Einigungen mit den Lehen
auch auch aus den letzten Jahren und der
eu-türkeier Erklärung arbeitet und dass
diese Einigungen dann einen Effekt haben
auf die Zahlen von denen die in
Deutschland
ankommen es geht ja in letzter Zeit es
fällt immer wieder dieses Stichwort
pullfaktoren sprich Anreize
Frank Blankenburg denkt es mal in die
andere Richtung er schreibt
Sachleistungen Prepaidkarten und
zeitliche Begrenzung dieser Maßnahmen
Übernahme der Rückreise Kosten mit einer
Art stkapital für den Aufbau im
Heimatland koppeln mit Ausschluss der
Wiedereinreise wäre das
was also das Prinzip der freiwilligen
Rückkehr ist seit Jahren eines der
Instrumente da wird angeboten dass Leute
zurückkehren in ganz wenigen Ländern
klappt es meistens klappt es in den
Ländern wo es auch eine realistische
Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt dass
Abschiebungen klappen
also in in die afrikanischen Länder eine
Zahl nur für Italien 200 Abschiebungen
im letzten Jahr in alle Länder subsahara
Afrikas da gibt's dann auch wenig
freiwillige Ausreise weil alle Leute
wissen sie haben es mal geschafft sie
haben die gefährliche Reise überlebt die
Chance abgeschoben zu werden ist minimal
und das ist überall in der EU so nicht
nur in Italien auch in Österreich
Spanien Frankreich oder Deutschland das
heißt die freiwillige Ausreise ist auch
sinnvoll wie vieles dass wir hier
besprechen aber sie wird nur eine
beschränkte Wirkung haben und wenn ich
dann höre man muss an vielen schrau
drehen und alles zusammen erzeugt den
Effekt m ja aber warum es jetzt geht ist
eine ein Wachstum ein starkes Wachstum
der irregulären die EU kommenden
Menschen bei den Zahlen schnell zu zu
reduzieren und
ja und darüber müsste man jetzt
eigentlich reden denn ansonsten wissen
wir auch wenn Menschen mal in der EU
sind dann und sie sprechen die
pullfaktoren an dann gehen sie dorthin
wo sie die Chance sehen
ein faires Verfahren zu bekommen wenn
sie zurecht Schutz suchen dann gehen sie
dorthin wo sie glauben dass sie Schutz
bekommen und interessant ist sie gehen
vor allem in zwei Länder und diese zwei
Länder nehmen immer mehr der geben immer
mehr positive Asylentscheidungen in den
letzten Jahren in der ganzen EU und das
sind Österreich und Deutschland
Österreich pro Kopf sogar noch mehr als
Deutschland positive Asylentscheidungen
in den letzten Jahren und das zeigt uns
dass es nicht an der Rhetorik liegt oder
an den an den Signalen oder an der willk
Kultur denn österreich hat eine Mitte
Rechtsregierung die fast so redet wie
Viktor Orban es liegt am Rechtsstaat das
ist etwas was Deutschland Österreich die
Schweiz Frankreich haben und das wissen
die die einen Asylantrag stellen und
deswegen kommen sie hierhin und
natürlich sind das alles auch reiche
Länder wo man wenn man anerkannt wird
und das sind ja die allermeisten werden
am Ende ja anerkannt hat man dann auch
eine Chance sein Leben aufzubauen also
diese pullfaktoren attraktiv zu sein
einen Rechtsstaat zu haben haben eine
starke Wirtschaft zu haben eine
Zivilgesellschaft zu haben die sich
kümmert die wird Deutschland nicht
abstellen können und ich glaube die wird
Deutschland auch nicht abstellen wollen
daher muss man anderes tun Herr Knaus
ich danke Ihnen sehr für dieses Gespräch
haben Sie noch einen schönen Abend
tschüss dan Ihnen auch alles Gute ja und
damit wollen wir uns für heute Abend
verabschieden wir werden sehen ob das
ein langer Abend oder vielleicht sogar
noch eine lange Nacht wird vielen Dank
für eure Fragen und Kommentare bis bald
mal macht gut
[Musik]
tschüss